you've heard of a slow news week this
was a stupid news week first of all let
me feel bad for the people who got hit
by the hurricane of course we wish the
Mele Spain possible but anytime there's
a hurricane the news turns into a wet
t-shirt contest it's not that with the
rain slicker I don't know if I'm
watching CNN or our dad for Gorton's
fish sticks what pisses me off is that
what's souping up the Hurricanes gets
less coverage hey media link those two
yeah I mean a report from the UN came at
the UN climate policy this this week
says this planet has like 20 good years
left if they say it could become
unlivable and I don't mean Tarzana
unlivable
I mean unlivable unlovable like guitars
at it's a great place but I mean can you
imagine that a UN report warning about
catastrophic damage from climate change
just as such a hurricane hits only a
[ __ ] could not see the connection or as
Trump said I don't see the connection
know that the hurricane is very much on
Trump's mind you had a whole roll of
paper towels duct - in June but yeah the
midterms are less than a month away
closing arguments Trump is calling the
Democrats an angry mob we're an angry
mob and the party of crime where the mob
we're in angry mcus the only liberals I
ever see with the pitchfork or
composting that's
this he says we're too dangerous to
govern we're to Daniel were the mob
too dangerous to govern and then he
mentioned dianne feinstein and the crowd
started to chant lock her up that's the
thing about a lynch mob they don't get
iron ii any woman like hillary lock
erupted i had fine scene lock her up
taylor swift what the hell lock her up
yeah well he still that taylor swift
came out for the democrats in tennessee
and trump does does not like that he did
i think what did it Taylor Swift reminds
him of hillary a powerful blonde woman
who has been rejected by millions of
white men there are reports now the
trump has finally agreed to talk to
robert muller will not talk but answer
15 questions in writing first questions
why did you let Kanye in the White House
to what is buffing 3 when you do your
hair and your makeup and you go outside
you do realize we can see you but if you
saw that this week but Donald Trump our
president held a meeting at the White
House to stress the importance of mental
health he didn't mean to but come on
well I mean really I mean Kanye West
called for the abolishing the amendment
that freed the slaves he said it was a
trapdoor for black people whatever that
means
and Trump was like you had me at
bringing back slavery but ton really I
mean some of the quotes are pretty
amazing he said this is our president he
has to be the freshest the flyest the
flyest planes the best factories and we
have to make our core be empowered and
Trump said I have no idea what you're
saying
and I can understand Melania you know
I mean
[Music]
Trump and Kanye one sang gold-digger one
married one
[Applause]
oh no she's just back from Africa she
said she's very happy to be home sure
there's no [ __ ] like but I mean that
meeting this weekend with Kanye it was
sad he said he was misdiagnosed with
bipolar disorder but it was really a
matter of sleep deprivation and then
Kanye said I have problems too and
it's Kanye Regin for 25 minutes and
Trump just sat there and listened and I
thought finally at least we found
someone who can make Trump shut the [ __ ]
up